how to remedy disease in livestock treat
the one or treat the head on average is
the latter
but is it right to give help the animals
antibiotics overuse of commonly used
antibiotics on animals end up in the
food chain can render them useless as
bacteria becomes resistant creating a
major public health crisis ciona an
animal Malad over his illicit animal is
allegedly said bond patek del wash
prohibiting coterminous or mess of -
everything : at least a sort of utakata
to poop
we haven't from spongy started thought
in the occasional yawn touch aunty we
couldn't be alerted stenson one does
this unacceptable we are all banned
phone outside una antibiotic are as the
alarms I hinted little circles the
veterinary pharmaceutical industry makes
them 4.6 billion sales across the EU but
it's been over 30 years since a new type
of antibiotic was developed on Wednesday
the Environment Committee voted in favor
of new legislation that would push for
greater research and development fight
incentives the sale of veterinary
antibiotics online will also be
prevented the new regulation could come
into effect by the end of 2018 or early
2019
you